- [Voiceover] So, I'm gonna give
another quick overview of photosynthesis.
And this time I'm gonna break
it down into two big stages.
So, as you are probably familiar,
just looking at the word, photosynthesis.
It essentially has two parts,
it has photo and it has synthesis.
The photo is referring to
that it's going to use light somehow.
And what's it going to do
with that light energy?
Well, it's going to synthesize something.
And, in particular, what
it's going to synthesize,
as we'll see, is sugar.
So, we are going to go
from energy in light,
let me just write light, light energy,
and we're going to use that
light energy to synthesize,
to synthesize, sugar,
very broadly speaking.
Obviously this is a very,
very high-level overview.
The light energy isn't
the only input here.
We're also going to need some water
and as we go into future videos,
we'll see what that water's used for.
It's actually a source of electrons.
To do this,
to make use of that light energy, frankly.
And we're also going to
need some carbon dioxide,
really as a source of carbons,
because there's a lot of
carbon in those sugars.
We're essentially going to fix the carbon.
We're gonna take it from
this carbon dioxide gas,
and we're going to incorporate
it into organic molecules
and eventually into the sugar.
And sugar isn't the only output.
Another bi-product of this
process is molecular oxygen.
Once you strip a couple of
electrons from the water,
and the hydrogen ions are
stripped away from it as well,
all you're left with is oxygen.
And you do that twice,
then you have o two and
you have molecular oxygen.
And this is a bi-product
of photosynthesis,
but you can imagine this is very important
to life on earth as we know it,
in particular for us.
We would have trouble breathing
if this was not a bi-product
of photosynthesis.
Now what I'm gonna do
now is break this out
into two stages.
And these two stages,
we can call the light-dependent reactions.
Light-dependent reactions,
and then the second stage,
I will call the Calvin cycle.
Calvin, Calvin, cycle.
And as the name implies,
the light-dependent reactions
are dependent on light.
So, what's happening here is,
we're gonna take light energy.
Light energy.
Plus we're gonna take the
water as a source of electrons,
and we're going to use these two things.
We're going to use these
two things to produce,
to produce, let me write
this in another color,
to produce ATP from ADP,
so we're gonna produce ATP,
which is a store of energy,
and we're also going to
reduce NADP plus into NADPH,
which has energy as a
strong reducing agent.
So this is what is
happening, broadly speaking,
in the light reactions.
And then in the Calvin
cycle, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take these products
of the light-dependent reactions,
so we're gonna take our ATP and our NADPH,
and we can use their energy in conjunction
with some carbon dioxide,
in order to produce,
in order to produce, sugar.
In order to produce sugar.
And, let me see, have
I got everything here?
Oh, of course, I'm missing
one of the bi-products
of the light-dependent reactions.
A very important one.
I'm missing the molecular,
the molecular oxygen.
So, once again, this is what
makes up photosynthesis,
but you can break it up
into these two segments.
Light-dependent reaction
is using the energy
from photons in light along
with electrons from the water
to produce, to store
energy, as ATP and NADPH,
and has oxygen, molecular
oxygen, as a bi-product.
In order for it to get
one molecular oxygen,
you're gonna have to need
two of these water molecules.
And then, as we go into the Calvin cycle,
we can take these, the ATP and the NADPH,
along with some carbon dioxide,
and we can use that to
actually store energy
as actual sugar.
And as we'll do in future videos,
we'll go into more depth and see
what exactly happens in these
light-dependent reactions,
and what exactly happens
in the Calvin cycle.